I show in that talk how my favorite algorithm, outer product, is basically just a composition of Cartesian product and chunk, the view that we just mentioned. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 91, recorded on August 9th, 2022. My name is Connor and today with my co-host Bryce, we continue part two of our two-part conversation on what to look forward to in C++23. But we'll start with zip. So I'm trying to get back to them. So zip is the first time I came across zip was in Python. And what Zip does is it takes two equal length sequences or ranges and combines them so that you get a single sequence of tuples. You can actually take an arbitrary number of sequences.
我在那次演讲中展示了我最喜欢的算法——外积（outer product），基本上只是笛卡尔积（Cartesian product）和分块（chunk）的组合，也就是我们刚刚提到的视角。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 91 期，本期节目于 2022 年 8 月 9 日录制。我是康纳（Connor），今天我和我的联合主持布莱斯（Bryce）将继续关于 C++23 值得期待的内容的第二部分讨论。但我们要从 zip 开始。所以我要试着回到正题。所以 zip 是我第一次在 Python 中遇到的。而 zip 的作用是，它接受两个等长的序列或范围，并将它们组合起来，使你得到一个由元组组成单一序列。你实际上可以接受任意数量的序列。
The most common, I think, is two of them, but you can take an arbitrary number. If you want to take five, it'll return you a five tuple back, a sequence of five tuples. So very nice. Zip transform is more commonly known as just map in other languages. In Haskell, it's known as zip with. We called it transform because in C++, we use transform as our mapping algorithm name and it basically takes an arbitrary number of equal length sequences and then a function that has the arity equal to the number of sequences you take so the simplest example is you take two sequences and a binary function so for example two sequences and the std colon colon plus or a
我认为最常见的是两个，但你可以接受任意数量。如果你想取五个，它会返回给你一个五元组，一个由五元组组成的序列。所以这非常棒。Zip 变换（Zip transform）在其他语言中通常被称为 map。在 Haskell 中，它被称为 zip with。我们称之为 transform 是因为在 C++ 中，我们使用 transform 作为我们的映射算法名称，它基本上接受任意数量的等长序列，然后是一个元数（arity）等于你所接受序列数量的函数，所以最简单的例子是你接受两个序列和一个二元函数，例如两个序列和一个 std::plus 或者一个
lambda that adds two numbers together. It can be any binary function. Binary here meaning a function that takes two arguments. You know, it doesn't actually need to be a function. It can be something else. Just as long as it's invocable or callable. And it returns you a single sequence and instead of tupling up those elements element-wise, it basically applies the binary function or the n-ary function to your n sequences. And so you end up with a sequence of whatever the return object of that binary function is. So technically you can think of zip as a specialization of zip transform where the n-ary function is makeple uh is a kind of easy way to think about that how about the chunk algorithms uh first let's do adjacent and adjacent transform because they're
把两个数字加在一起的 lambda。它可以是任何二元函数。这里的二元意味着一个接受两个参数的函数。你知道，它实际上不需要是一个函数。它可以是其他东西。只要它是可调用的（invocable or callable）就行。它返回给你一个单一序列，而不是逐元素地将这些元素打包成元组，它基本上是将二元函数或 n 元函数应用于你的 n 个序列。因此，最终你会得到一个序列，其类型就是该二元函数的返回对象类型。所以在技术上，你可以认为 zip 是 zip 专有化或特化版本，其中 n 元函数是 makeple —— 呃，这是一种比较容易理解的方式，那么分块（chunk）算法呢？首先让我们来看看相邻（adjacent）和相邻变换（adjacent transform），因为它们
next to zip so adjacent is basically a function that is a not i don't think specialization it's definitely not a specialization of zip and zip transform but they're sort of like uh sibling algorithms it takes two adjacent elements and tuples them together uh so you can think of this as similar to adjacent difference or adjacent find both of those algorithms are looking at adjacent elements this is basically just uh making tuples out of them adjacent transform is the exact same idea it's a a stenciling operator. It gives you sort of a stencil. Correct, yes. In a lot of the mathematical or HPC world, this is known as either tiling or stenciling.
紧挨着 zip。所以 adjacent 基本上是一个函数，它不是 —— 我不认为它是特化，它绝对不是 zip 和 zip 变换的特化，但它们有点像是同胞算法。它接受两个相邻的元素并将它们打包成元组 —— 所以你可以认为这类似于相邻差分（adjacent difference）或相邻查找（adjacent find），这两个算法都在查看相邻的元素，这基本上只是 —— 用它们制作元组。相邻变换完全是相同的概念，它是一个模板（stenciling）操作符。它给你提供了一种模板。没错，是的。在许多数学或高性能计算（HPC）世界中，这被称为分块（tiling）或模板（stenciling）操作。
What if I wanted three adjacent elements? Can I do that with the adjacent view? Yes. So actually, in the example, and it's actually sad that I don't know this off the top of my head. I think we ended up calling. So adjacent actually doesn't just look at two. You specify the number of elements you want to look at.
如果我想要三个相邻的元素呢？我可以用 adjacent view 做到这一点吗？是的。事实上，在示例中，很遗憾我记不清具体细节了。我想我们最后把 —— 所以 adjacent 实际上不仅查看两个。你可以指定你想要查看的元素数量。
And we have a specialization for the one that takes two. And it looks like we called it pairwise. Let me just confirm that because that kind of makes me sad. It's not on CPP reference yet. Yeah, I was going to say it's not on the cpp reference compiler support page but sai has an example that says stood colon colon views colon colon pairwise i'm wonder if this compiles is there is there gobble links in here there's not gobble links in here is there a gobble link at the bottom although potentially cy works at microsoft correct right so cy might be using an internal version of msvc that has this stuff implemented because msvc is leading the
我们为只取两个的那种情况提供了一个特化版本。看起来我们把它叫做 pairwise（成对）。让我确认一下，因为这让我有点难过。它还没在 CPP reference 上线。是的，我要说的是，它不在 cpp reference 的编译器支持页面上，但 sai 有一个例子，里面写着 std::views::pairwise。我在想这能编译吗？这里有 gobble 链接吗？这里没有 gobble 链接。底部有一个 gobble 链接吗？虽然可能 sai 在微软工作，对吧？对，所以 sai 可能在使用内部版本的 msvc，其中已经实现了这些东西，因为 msvc 正在走在
charge on implementing these so i think yeah i will come back and edit this as if i'm incorrect but yeah pairwise i think is the specialization that takes two at a time. And the transform version of adjacent. So adjacent transform does the same thing as zip transform, it takes an elements and an an arity, invocable or callable thing, and then applies that to the elements. And I'll speed up here, chunk, and chunk by so chunk takes a range or a sequence and integer value and basically creates a range of ranges where each of those ranges takes n elements at a time. So for instance, if you have an iota sequence of 1 to 10 and you go chunk 5, it'll give you a range of two ranges from 1 to 5 and 6 to 10. And chunk by is actually a little bit difficult to explain. It's very easy to show
实现这些功能的前沿。所以我想，是的，如果我记错了，我会回来编辑这个。但是是的，pairwise 我认为是每次取两个的特化版本。而 adjacent 的 transform 版本。所以 adjacent transform 做的事情和 zip transform 一样，它接受元素和 n 元、可调用或可唤醒的事物，然后将其应用于元素。我在这里加快速度，chunk 和 chunk by —— 所以 chunk 接受一个范围或序列以及一个整数值，基本上创建一个范围的范围（range of ranges），其中每一个范围每次取 n 个元素。例如，如果你有一个从 1 到 10 的 iota 序列，然后你调用 chunk 5，它会给你一个包含两个范围的范围，从 1 到 5 以及从 6 到 10。而 chunk by 实际上有点难以解释。展示起来却非常简单
though. It basically does the same kind of chunking behavior. So these are what are known as anamorphic algorithms. You start with a sequence and then you end up with a sequence of sequences or something like that. And chunk by basically takes a binary operation, an invocable thing that takes two arguments, and creates a new sequence. Anytime the binary operation, technically it's a binary predicate. So it returns true or false, uh, turns, um, returns false. So the easiest example, or one of the easiest examples is if you go one, one, one, two, two, two, three, three, three, and you call chunk by on that sequence with a stood colon colon equal to binary operation. That'll then give you a range
不过。它基本上做了同一种分块行为。所以这些就是所谓的 anamorphic（同构变形）算法。你从一个序列开始，然后最终得到一个序列的序列或类似的东西。chunk by 基本上接受一个二元操作，一个接受两个参数的可调用事物，并创建一个新序列。任何时候二元操作 —— 技术上它是一个二元谓词。所以它返回 true 或 false，呃，返回 —— 返回 false。所以最简单的例子，或者最简单的例子之一是，如果你输入 1, 1, 1, 2, 2, 2, 3, 3, 3，然后你在该序列上调用 chunk by，并使用 std::equal 作为二元操作。这随后会给你一个
of three ranges where the sub ranges are equal to one, one, one in the first one, two to two in the second one and three through three in the third one. Or I think perhaps a more intuitive one is if you have a function that tells you when you're at the end of a word and then you run it over a string, it will give you all of the words in the string. Right, and what would the binary operation for that be? So that's a little bit tricky, because I was like, you could use the one where you just check whether the left character is not in white space,
包含三个范围的范围，其中子范围在第一个中等于 1, 1, 1，在第二个中等于 2, 2, 2，在第三个中等于 3 到 3。或者我认为也许更直观的例子是，如果你有一个函数，它能告诉你什么时候到达一个单词的末尾，然后你对一个字符串运行它，它就会给你字符串中的所有单词。对，那这个的二元操作会是什么呢？所以这有点棘手，因为我想：你可以使用这样一种方法，即只检查左边的字符是不是空白字符，
the right character is white space, but then you wouldn't actually get the words, because you would then get, like the first word would just be the word, but then the second word would have the whitespace before it. And also that doesn't handle things like punctuation. But I just sort of meant like intuitively, if you have like a very simple string. I want you to spell it out. Character by character, Bryce. I'm just kidding. I mean, if you really wanted to get just the words, what you could do is you could do that simple function of like, is the left character non-whitespace?
右边的字符是不是空白字符，但那样你实际上就得不到那些单词了，因为你会得到 —— 比如第一个单词确实就是这个单词，但第二个单词会在前面带上之前的空白字符。而且这也无法处理标点符号之类的事情。但我只是凭直觉说，如果你有一个非常简单的字符串。我需要你把它拼出来。逐个字符地拼出来，布莱斯。我开玩笑呢。我的意思是，如果你真的只想得到这些单词，你可以做的是：你可以写那个简单的函数，比如：左边的字符不是空白字符吗？
Is the right character whitespace? And then the results of that adjacent, you could pipe into a trim that goes through each one of the sub-sequences and trims out the white space characters. And then you would get a range that is a range of the range of words in your stream. Yeah. And these algorithms are super common in sort of functional languages. So I believe Haskell calls chunk by group by. And the specialization that uses the binary operation, where it's equal to stood colon, colon equal to or lambda, that's just checking if two things are equal is called group.
右边的字符是空白字符吗？然后，你可以将该相邻操作的结果管道传输（pipe into）一个 trim 操作，该操作遍历每一个子序列并修剪掉空白字符。然后你就会得到一个范围，它是一个包含你的流中单词范围的范围。是的。这些算法在某种函数式编程语言中非常常见。所以我相信 Haskell 将 chunk by 称为 group by。而使用二元操作的特化版本，即等于 std::equal 或 lambda 的版本，它只是检查两个事物是否相等，被称为 group。
But a variety of language, I know D calls this chunk by that's actually where we got the name from it. We got the name from we borrowed it from the D language, although there's a couple other languages that also call it this. And I think actually I gave, I actually don't know if it was covered in that talk. I gave a CPPCon lightning talk at some point called chunk, slide and stride, I believe. And it was sort of talking about these views and how they're very similar to each other. Slide is another one that basically you can think of as a chunk, but instead of stepping by the number, the size of your chunk, you're stepping by one. So chunk, if you specify in the example where I did one to 10 and you chunk by five and you end up with two chunks, that is basically chunking by five and then stepping your start of your next chunk by five. But slide only steps by one. So if you did
但在各种语言中，我知道 D 语言称之为 chunk by —— 这实际上也是我们获取这个名字的来源。我们从 D 语言那里借用了这个名字，尽管还有其他几门语言也这样称呼它。而且我实际上给过 —— 我其实不知道那次演讲中是否涵盖了这一点。我曾经在某个时候做过一次 CPPCon 闪电演讲，叫做 chunk、slide 和 stride，我相信是这个名字。它大致讨论了这些视图以及它们彼此之间是多么相似。Slide 是另一个你可以认为类似于 chunk 的概念，但它不是按块的大小（即你的块的大小）进行步进，而是按 1 进行步进。所以 chunk，如果你指定了我之前做的 1 到 10 的例子，然后你按 5 进行 chunk，你最终会得到两个 chunk，这基本上就是按 5 分块，然后将下一个 chunk 的起点步进 5。但 slide 只步进 1。所以如果你对
one to 10, chunk five, you'd get one to five, two to six, three to seven, et cetera, until you got to the end. And so slide is, I think of in another way, is sort of a stenciling operation. Yep. Yeah. Actually, what is the relation between slide and adjacent? I want to say adjacent has a compile time, a compile time slice length or window length,
1 到 10 执行 chunk 5，你会得到 1 到 5、2 到 6、3 到 7 等等，一直到末尾。所以 slide，从另一个角度来看，我将其视为一种模板（stenciling）操作。是的。是的。事实上，slide 和 adjacent 之间有什么关系？我想说 adjacent 具有编译期 —— 编译期的切片长度或窗口长度，
whereas slide is runtime. I could actually be wrong about that. I mean, Barry Revzin is the one that did all the heavy lifting on this stuff, and I recall initially asking the exact same question. I i was like why do we need two different versions of these and then the response was well you know a lot of the times you actually know the stencil or window length at compile time and that leads to a completely different performance
而 slide 是运行时的。关于这一点我其实可能记错了。我的意思是，巴里·雷夫津（Barry Revzin）是在这方面做了所有繁重工作的人，我记得我最初问过完全相同的问题。我当时问：为什么我们需要这两种不同的版本？然后得到的回答是：嗯，你知道，很多时候你实际上在编译期就知道模板或窗口长度，这会带来完全不同的性能
profile and algorithm implementation so um yeah it's a great question that i think about it if it's if it's if you know it at compile time, you can just pass a tuple or a pair. Right. Whereas if it's at runtime, then you have to pass a range, and then you have to iterate through the range. Right, and I think that's the key difference as well. Like adjacent returns you back a tuple, whereas slide.
配置文件和算法实现。所以，是的，这是一个很好的问题，仔细想想，如果 —— 如果你在编译期就知道它，你就可以直接传递一个元组或对（pair）。对。而如果是运行时，你就必须传递一个范围，然后你必须遍历这个范围。对，我认为这也是关键区别所在。就像 adjacent 返回给你一个元组，而 slide 则是……
So adjacent returns you back a range of tuples, whereas slide returns you having a range in your range is going to affect very significantly what the next pipeable thing you do can do. Because if you want to get the last element or the first element, having a tuple or a range is obviously, it's going to be less or more ergonomic depending on what you're doing.
所以 adjacent 返回给你一个由元组组成的范围，而 slide 返回给你的范围中包含的范围，将非常显著地影响你接下来能做的下一个可管道化操作。因为如果你想获取最后一个元素或第一个元素，拥有一个元组或一个范围，显然，根据你在做什么，它会更符合人体工程学或不那么符合。
Yeah. So one of the other range views, which was a paper that Sai originally wrote, but then some folks at NVIDIA, in particular my colleague Mihao, finished and got into C++23, is the Cartesian product view, which is a range adapter that takes multiple input ranges. And it produces a range of all of the ordered tuples formed by taking an element from each one of the inputs.
是的。因此，另一个 range view 是最初由 Sai 撰写的一篇论文，后来由 NVIDIA 的一些员工，特别是我的同事米豪（Mihao）完成并引入 C++23 的是笛卡尔积视图（Cartesian product view），它是一个接受多个输入范围的范围适配器。它生成一个由所有有序元组组成的范围，这些有序元组是通过从每个输入中取出一个元素形成的。
So this one is near and dear to my heart because it's very useful for constructing ranges that iterate through a multidimensional index space. So like if you take a Cartesian product of two iota views, an iota view from 0 to n and an iota view from 0 to m, that Cartesian product of those two views will give you back a range of two element tuples from 0, 0 to n minus 1, m minus 1. Yep, it's very nice. Cartesian product is awesome to have. And if you watch the talk that I mentioned
所以这个对我来说非常亲切，因为对于构造遍历多维索引空间的范围非常有用。比如，如果你取两个 iota 视图的笛卡尔积，一个从 0 到 n 的 iota 视图和一个从 0 到 m 的 iota 视图，这两个视图的笛卡尔积将返回一个由两元素元组组成的范围，从 (0, 0) 到 (n - 1, m - 1)。是的，这非常棒。拥有笛卡尔积真是太棒了。如果你看了我提到的那次演讲——
in the last episode or two episodes ago that I said was live streaming in 27 minutes, I show in that talk how my favorite algorithm, outer product, is basically just a composition of Cartesian product and chunk, the view that we just mentioned. Because our outer product is basically just a structured Cartesian product that if you're given two sequences with length n and m, it'll create basically a matrix or a range of ranges with lengths n and m. It'll create basically a matrix or a range of ranges with lengths n and m. And so you can basically just call Cartesian product, then views transform and std apply whatever binary operation you want to that sequence. And then you just call chunk with the either n or m and you're good to go, which is very, very nice. Maybe we'll get other products probably not there's three other i think um or two other views worth mentioning um stride and repeat stride kind of completes the set of chunk
在上一集或两集前我说过将在 27 分钟后进行直播的那次演讲——我在那次演讲中展示了我最喜欢的算法外积（outer product），本质上只是笛卡尔积和我们刚刚提到的 view 的组合。因为我们的外积本质上只是一个结构化的笛卡尔积，如果你给定两个长度分别为 n 和 m 的序列，它基本上会创建一个长度为 n 和 m 的矩阵或范围的范围。它基本上会创建一个长度为 n 和 m 的矩阵或范围的范围。因此你基本上只需调用笛卡尔积，然后调用 views transform 并用 std::apply 对该序列应用你想要的任何二元操作。然后你只需用 n 或 m 调用 chunk，就大功告成了，这真的非常非常棒。也许我们会得到外积，可能不会，还有另外三个，我想 —— 或者另外两个值得一提的 view —— stride 和 repeat。Stride 基本上完善了 chunk
and slide where chunk is windowing size of n step size of n slide is windowing size of n step size of n. Slide is windowing size of n, step size of one. And stride is windowing size of one, step size of n. In other words, in some languages, this is called every nth. So if you specify stride of four, it just looks at every fourth element, which can be very useful if you're trying to skip over certain things. And repeat, I don't think need to sort of say what that is. You should explain it. Okay, well, actually, repeat was not one. I wonder if repeat and cycle, let's look at the paper. Because so there's two possible things that I actually don't know which one this does.
和 slide 的集合，其中 chunk 的窗口大小为 n，步长为 n，slide 的窗口大小为 n，步长为 n。Slide 的窗口大小为 n，步长为 1。而 stride 的窗口大小为 1，步长为 n。换句话说，在某些语言中，这被称为 every nth（每隔 n 个）。因此，如果你指定 stride 为 4，它只会查看每四个元素，如果你想跳过某些特定的东西，这会非常有用。至于 repeat，我觉得不需要解释那是什么了。你应该解释一下。好吧，事实上，repeat 并不是其中之一。我在想 repeat 和 cycle 是怎样的，让我们看一下这篇论文。因为实际上有两种可能的情况，我其实不知道这个做的是哪一种。
Does it repeat infinitely? Or do you specify that you want to repeat something n number of times because if you have cycle repeating infinitely is basically just a special case of cycle where you only have one element cycle is um a view where if you have the elements one two three four five and you want to repeat that sequence infinitely views repeat will repeat it either infinitely or a specified number of times but do you know why repeat is in c++ 23 i mean you me how wrote the proposal Right, but you are actually responsible for it. Oh, is it because of that one problem that we were solving where you had to normalize a list of numbers?
它是无限重复吗？还是你指定了你想要重复某个东西 n 次？因为如果你有 cycle，无限重复基本上只是 cycle 的一个特例，其中你只有一个元素。Cycle 是一个 —— 如果你拥有元素 1、2、3、4、5，并且你想要无限重复该序列，views repeat 将会无限重复它，或者重复指定的次数。但是你知道为什么 repeat 会出现在 C++23 中吗？我的意思是，你 —— 米豪写了这份提案。
And then you were like, what's the way to do it? And I was like, oh, well, you just do this with a fork and APL. I think literally we solved this live on one of our episodes. So the problem was how do you do a – like you want to normalize a vector. So you want to go and find the smallest element of a vector. So like a min element. And then you want to divide every element of the vector
对，但你实际上要为此负责。哦，是因为我们当时在解决的那个问题吗？当时你必须对一组数字进行归一化。然后你就问：有什么方法可以做到这一点？然后我就说：哦，好吧，你只要用 fork 和 APL 就能做到这一点。我想我们确实在我们的某期节目中现场解决了这个问题。所以当时的问题是：你如何做 —— 比如你想归一化一个向量。所以你想去找到向量中的最小元素。比如 min element。然后你想把向量中的每一个元素
by that minimum element. And I like this example because it's an example of a problem that doesn't neatly fit into the piping syntax because you've got an input sequence to that min element and then the min element produces you know a scalar value and then you want to feed the input sequence and that scalar value into the next thing in your pipeline, the transform. And so I often use this as an example of where the piping syntax breaks down, because you're not just passing the same single input sequence
通过这个最小元素。我喜欢这个例子，因为它是一个不能很好地契合管道语法的例子，因为你有一个到那个最小元素的输入序列，然后最小元素产生一个标量值，然后你想把输入序列和那个标量值喂给管道中的下一个东西，即转换。所以我经常用这个作为管道语法失效的例子，因为你不仅仅是在传递相同的单一输入序列
between stages of the pipeline. And I showed this to Connor, and Connor was like, oh, well, you should just be using repeat here. And I don't remember the exact details of it as once you've calculated the minimum, instead of capturing that minimum in a lambda and then calling a views transform over your initial sequence and then basically dividing each of those elements by the minimum, you could alternatively do zip transform where your two sequences or ranges are your initial range and then views repeat of the minimum and then you your binary operation is uh divide and that falls out of a sort of apl array language solution where you'd solve this with a monadic fork or what's known as
除以那个最小元素。我喜欢这个例子，因为它是一个不能很好地契合管道语法（piping syntax）的问题的例子，因为你有一个输入序列传给 min element，然后 min element 产生了一个标量值，接着你想把输入序列和这个标量值一起喂给管道中的下一个东西——transform。所以我经常把这个例子当作管道语法失效的地方，因为你不仅仅是在管道的各个阶段之间传递相同的单个输入序列。
a phi combinator and commentary logic so connor showed me this and i I was like, huh. And then I took a little bit more of a look at repeat, and I was like, you know, we have all these fancy iterators in the thrust library, which is our parallel algorithms library that inspired the C++17 parallel algorithms, but also predates them and predates ranges. And so it had to introduce some of its own fancy iterators. And do you know which fancy iterator and thrust repeat corresponds to you're asking this question and literally uh one second before i stopped talking i was like oh i should also mention that but then you started talking i was like i'll wait for bryce to finish but like so the next thing i was going to say was that this also corresponds to if you use the boost fancy iterators thrust the constant iterator yes and so i saw that and i was like huh and i looked through the rest of the thrust fancy iterators and i'm like well we have we have views transform we have zip it seems like the only one that's
一个 phi 组合子和注释逻辑，所以康纳向我展示了这个，然后我就觉得，嗯。然后我更仔细地看了一下 repeat，我就觉得，你知道，我们在 thrust 库中拥有所有这些奇特的迭代器，这是我们的并行算法库，它激发了 C++17 的并行算法，但它也比它们出现得更早，也比 ranges 出现得更早。所以它必须引入一些它自己的奇特的迭代器。你知道 thrust repeat 对应于哪个奇特的迭代器吗？你问这个问题，就在我停止说话前的一秒钟，我就想，哦，我应该也提一下那个，但然后你开始说话了，我就想，我等布萊斯说完，但是，接下来我要说的是，这也对应于如果你使用 boost 的奇特的迭代器，thrust 的常量迭代器，是的，所以我看到了，然后我就想，嗯，然后我浏览了其余的 thrust 奇特的迭代器，我想，嗯，我们有 views transform，我们有 zip，看起来唯一的一个
missing is iota as well yeah views iota as. It seems like the only thrust fancy iterator that does not have a corresponding counterpart in ranges is repeat. And so after that, I was like, well, that's interesting because we have a lot of thrust users that are asking me, how do I useFancy iterators with the C++ parallel algorithms? And I tell them, well, you could just include them and use them. But I was like, well, what if they didn't need to? What if I could just tell them to use C++20 ranges? Because we now have range views that correspond to all of the ThrustFancy iterators. And then I started looking into that.
缺少的是 iota，是的，views iota。看起来唯一没有在 ranges 中找到对应项的 thrust 奇特的迭代器就是 repeat。所以在那之后，我就觉得，嗯，这很有趣，因为我们有很多 thrust 用户在问我，我该如何将奇特的迭代器与 C++ 并行算法一起使用？我告诉他们，嗯，你可以直接包含它们并使用它们。但我觉得，如果他们不需要这样做呢？如果我可以直接告诉他们使用 C++20 ranges 呢？因为我们现在有了与所有 Thrust 奇特的迭代器相对应的 range views。然后我开始研究这个。
And as it turned out, there were some bugs in the specification that prevented you from passing the range view iterators into the parallel algorithms. And so then I talked to my colleague, David Olson, and I'm like, hey, can you fix this? And he wrote a paper to fix that. And then I was like, you know what? And then we need repeat. And so I talked to my colleague, Michal Domenech, and I said, hey, can you fix this and he wrote a paper to fix that and then i was like you know what and then we need repeat and so i talked to my colleague mija domenic and i said hey can you write this paper for repeat and also for cartesian product and he did that and and that's why we have those things in c++ 23 and now in c++ 23 you can completely replace any of your thrust algorithm plus thrust fancy iterator usage with just
事实证明，规范中存在一些错误，阻止你将 range view 迭代器传递给并行算法。于是我和我的同事大卫·奥尔森（David Olson）谈了谈，我说，嘿，你能修复这个吗？他写了一篇论文来修复它。然后我想，你知道吗？然后我们需要 repeat。所以我跟我的同事米哈尔·多梅内克（Michal Domenech）谈了谈，我说，嘿，你能修复这个吗，他写了一篇论文来修复它，然后我想，你知道吗，然后我们需要 repeat，所以我跟我的同事米哈尔·多梅内克谈了谈，我说，嘿，你能为 repeat 写这篇论文吗，也为笛卡尔积写，他照做了，这就是为什么我们在 C++ 23 中有这些东西，现在在 C++ 23 中，你可以完全用
completely standard code. Yep. And to go through the list, well, I'm looking at the... And so if people are wondering what it is that I actually do it in video, that's what I do it in video. Well, to be fair, the thrust fancy iterators were completely borrowed from the boost fancy iterators. Yes, yeah. And if we go through those, I'll skip a few that are sort of more esoteric, but zip iterator corresponds to view zip.
完全标准的代码来替换你任何的 thrust 算法加 thrust 奇特的迭代器的用法。是的。回顾一下这个列表，嗯，我正在看……所以如果人们想知道我在英伟达实际上做的是什么，这就是我在英伟达做的事情。嗯，公平地说，thrust 奇特的迭代器完全是从 boost 奇特的迭代器借来的。是的，是的。如果我们遍历这些，我会跳过一些更深奥的，zip 迭代器对应于 view zip。
Transform iterator corresponds to views transform. Reverse iterator corresponds to views reverse. Filter iterator, didn't even actually know that one existed because i don't think that exists in thrust um corresponds to views filter and counting iterator uh corresponds to views iota yeah and uh that's pretty yeah it's pretty awesome these things are at first you'd think that they're not super like the utility of them you're like how often would I reach for this? But once you start to reach for them, you start to notice that they are like, and the constant iterator, for some reason, isn't actually in the specialized adapters list, but I know it is a part of this library. And that's what corresponds to views repeat. They are very, very useful utilities.
Transform 迭代器对应于 views transform。Reverse 迭代器对应于 views reverse。Filter 迭代器，甚至不知道那个存在，因为我不认为它存在于 thrust 中，嗯，对应于 views filter，而 counting 迭代器对应于 views iota，是的，呃，这真的很，是的，真的很棒，这些东西，一开始你会觉得它们不是超级……比如它们的效用，你会想你会多久使用一次这个？但一旦你开始使用它们，你就会开始注意到它们就像……而且常量迭代器，由于某种原因，其实不在专门的适配器列表中，但我知道它是这个库的一部分。这就是对应于 views repeat 的东西。它们是非常非常有用的工具。
There is one that I believe we don't have a counterpart for. And I don't know whether boost iterators have it. The discard iterator in Thrust. Have you ever used that one? That does exist in Thrust. That does exist. I know of it. I've never personally used it, but I've seen it in code reviews in Rapids where it basically yeets it, right? Yeah, so the discard iterator is an iterator that
有一个我相信我们没有对应项。我不知道 boost 迭代器是否有它。Thrust 中的 discard 迭代器。你用过那个吗？那确实存在于 Thrust 中。那确实存在。我知道它。我从没亲自用过它，但我见过它在 Rapids 的代码审查中，它基本上就是把它丢掉，对吧？是的，所以 discard 迭代器是一个迭代器
that you can you know light to and it just does nothing so if you have an if you want to call an algorithm but you don't care about the output then you'd call the discard you'd use the discard iterator yeah it's uh it's useful it's very useful in certain situations where it's exactly what you need. I can't think of an example off the top of my head. It definitely, I'm not going to remember it, but I definitely know if you search in the Rapids libcudf code base, almost definitely you're going to find an example of it. Speaking of all of this stuff, I feel bad not having Barry on.
你可以，你知道，写入它，它什么也不做，所以如果你有一个，如果你想调用一个算法，但你不在乎输出，那么你就会调用 discard，你就会使用 discard 迭代器，是的，它是，它很有用，在某些情况下非常有用，正是你所需要的。我脑子里想不出一个例子。它绝对，我不会记住它，但我绝对知道如果你在 Rapids libcudf 代码库中搜索，几乎肯定会找到一个例子。说到所有这些东西，我觉得没有把巴里（Barry）请来很遗憾。
We should have, after we have Kate on, Barry on to talk about, this isn't even, I mean, I'm not sure if he's going to be upset that I'm mentioning it. It's going to become a paper at some point. He's got a Pipeline 2.0 paper in the works. That I'm really excited about. That is something I've really been spending. I just earlier today was spending some time looking at the Julia language. And yeah, the Julia has, Julia has a pipeline operator, but it only works on unary functions. And if you want to, it to work on binary functions, you have to, you have to use a macro called app pipe. And then it
我们应该在请了凯特（Kate）之后，把巴里请来谈谈这个，甚至都不是，我的意思是，我不确定他会不会因为我提到这个而不高兴。这在某个时候会变成一篇论文。他有一篇关于 Pipeline 2.0 的论文正在筹备中。我真的很兴奋。这是我真正花时间研究的事情。就在今天早些时候，我花了一些时间研究 Julia 语言。是的，Julia 有，Julia 有一个管道操作符，但它只对单目函数有效。如果你想让它对双目函数有效，你必须，你必须使用一个叫做 app pipe 的宏。然后它
also introduces a placeholder or the underbar where you specify where it goes. And in this 2.0 paper, I mean, he talks about in his initial paper as well. He talks about the, I mean, version one of his initial paper didn't have the placeholder version two does, and then his 2.0. So there's R1 and R2 of his first pipeline paper, and he's working on 2.0. So it's not a revised R version. It's a whole new paper with, it's going to have a whole new paper number. And I think it's incredibly important that we choose the right model because I am really leaning towards these days, the placeholder model, because it really kind of almost replaces the need for the kind of combinator things that I love. Like when you want to fork the output of an operation into two different
还引入了一个占位符或下划线，你在那里指定它去哪里。在这篇 2.0 论文中，我的意思是，他在最初的论文中也谈到了这一点。他谈到了，我的意思是，他的第一篇论文的第一版没有占位符，第二版有，然后是他的 2.0。所以他的第一篇管道论文有 R1 和 R2，他正在写 2.0。所以这不是一个修订版的 R 版本。这是一篇全新的论文，它将有一个全新的论文编号。我认为我们选择正确的模型是非常重要的，因为这些天我真的很倾向于占位符模型，因为它几乎取代了我所喜欢的那些组合子的需求。就像当你想要将一个操作的输出分叉到两个不同的
places, you can do that with the placeholder. And a great example of this is zip-width. Even when you don't want to pipe it into multiple places, but zip-width, because it is variadic in the number of sequences it can take, the variadic argument goes last. And that means that the first argument to zip-width, or sorry, zip-transform is what we call it. Zip with is the Haskell name. The first argument to that view is actually the invocable or callable thing with arity equal to the number of variadic sequences you're taking, which means that you can't actually use it with the pipe operator, because the way the pipe operator works with views is it pipes it into the first argument of your view so if it's if you don't if you can't design a view that is for some reason variatic such as zip or i think adjacent might be the same way i haven't used that yet
地方时，你可以用占位符来做到这一点。一个很好的例子就是 zip-width。即使当你不想把它管道化到多个地方时，但 zip-width，因为它可以接受的序列数量是可变的，所以可变参数放在最后。这意味着 zip-width 的第一个参数，或者抱歉，我们称之为 zip-transform。Zip with 是 Haskell 中的名字。该视图的第一个参数实际上是可调用对象，其元数等于你所接受的可变序列的数量，这意味着你实际上不能将它与管道操作符一起使用，因为管道操作符与视图协同工作的方式是将它管道化到你的视图的第一个参数中，所以如果它，如果你不能设计一个由于某种原因具有可变性的视图，例如 zip，或者我认为 adjacent 可能是相同的，我还没用过那个
you're not going to be able to use it with the pipeline operator or sorry the pipe operator so having a placeholder anyways i'm rambling but the point is we should bring Barry on, talk about all the different trade-offs, because I really want to get this right in C++. BARRY SCHWARTZMANN Yeah, we should have Barry on. And yeah, I'm very excited by that proposal. I have found an example. There's only one example in the Thrust examples of a usage
你将无法将它与管道操作符一起使用，或者抱歉是管道操作符，所以无论如何有一个占位符，我在胡言乱语，但重点是，我们应该把巴里请来，讨论所有不同的权衡，因为我真的很想在 C++ 中把这个做好。BARRY SCHWARTZMANN 是的，我们应该把巴里请来。是的，我对这个提案非常兴奋。我找到了一个例子。在 Thrust 示例中只有一个关于
of discard iterator. It is, the discard iterator is used extensively in the Thrust tests, unsurprisingly. And I believe one of the main use cases there is to make sure that things don't modify the input. So to run a test with a big data set where there's just an input. But there's a thrust example where it wants to do
discard 迭代器用法的例子。不出所料，discard 迭代器在 Thrust 测试中被广泛使用。我相信其中的主要用例之一是确保事物不会修改输入。即使用一个只有输入的大型数据集来运行测试。但有一个 thrust 示例，它想要进行
a set intersection and then store the resulting set. And if you do this, you have to allocate storage for the output. Now you could conservatively allocate storage. The maximum size of the intersection would be the size of the first set plus the size of the second set if there's nothing in them that, or this is an intersection, not a union. So I don't know what the maximum size would be.
集合求交集然后存储结果集合。如果你这样做，你必须为输出分配存储空间。现在你可以保守地分配存储空间。如果它们里面没有任何东西，交集的最大大小将是第一个集合的大小加上第二个集合的大小，或者这是一个交集，而不是一个并集。所以原谅我不知道最大大小会是多少。
I guess, no, I guess the maximum size would be the size of the largest set, right? If you have two sets that intersect, the maximum possible answer is the maximum of the two. Correct, yeah. Yeah. If they're completely mutually exclusive in their elements, it'll be just the length of both added together. But that might allocate more storage than you need so alternatively what you can do is you could compute the output size by outputting to a discard iterator so set intersection the algorithm takes you know the range of the input uh sets so two ranges and then it takes an output iterator to write to um and it returns um uh the uh the end of where it wrote to.
我想，不，我想最大大小将是最大集合的大小，对吧？如果你有两个相交的集合，最大可能的答案是两者中的最大值。没错，是的。是的。如果它们的元素完全互斥，它将是两者相加的长度。但这可能会分配比你需要的更多的存储空间，因此另一种方法是，你可以通过输出到一个 discard 迭代器来计算输出大小，所以集合交集算法需要你知道输入集合的范围，嗯，两个范围，然后它需要一个输出迭代器来写入，并且它返回嗯，嗯，它写入到的终点。
In discard iterators, while it doesn't store anything, it does keep track of how many times it's been incremented. So if you call set intersection with your two input sets and then with a discard iterator for the output set, set intersection will return you an iterator, a discard iterator, which you can do iterator difference between that return value and the beginning and you can get the size of the set intersection and then you can allocate only that storage now that's you know more computationally intensive because you're essentially going to do the center section twice
在 discard 迭代器中，虽然它不存储任何东西，但它确实会记录它被递增了多少次。因此，如果你用你的两个输入集合调用集合求交集，然后为输出集合使用一个 discard 迭代器，集合求交集将返回给你一个迭代器，一个 discard 迭代器，你可以对该返回值和起点进行迭代器差值运算，你可以获得集合交集的尺寸，然后你就可以只分配那个存储空间，现在你知道，这在计算上更密集，因为你本质上要做两次交集运算
but it does save on storage and that might be useful if you're doing things in parallel. Because then if you're doing things in parallel on the GPU, the additional cost of doing the computation twice may not be that important, but conserving memory may be quite important. So that's an interesting use case for it. I would suspect that there's probably some use cases where I have a feeling that somebody has said that they've used a scarred iterator with a scan, where they wanted to essentially do a reduction-like operation, but they didn't care about the output.
但这确实节省了存储空间，如果你在并行做事，这可能会很有用。因为如果你在 GPU 上并行做事，进行两次计算的额外成本可能没那么重要，但节省内存可能非常重要。所以这是一个有趣的用例。我怀疑可能有一些用例，我有种感觉，有人说过他们在 scan 中使用了 discard 迭代器，他们基本上想做类似归减的操作，但他们不在乎输出。
I think something like that, I recall from the past. Yeah, we'll definitely add links in the show notes. I'll see if I can find the example from Rapids that uses it in the wild. And perhaps we should write a paper proposing a discard iterator for standard C++ so that we can truly say that all of the thrust fancy iterators are available. By we, you mean the collective community at large. I completely agree. I meant you.
我想类似的事情，我从过去记忆中想起来。是的，我们肯定会在节目笔记中添加链接。我会看看能否找到 Rapids 中在实际中用到它的例子。也许我们应该写一篇论文，提议为标准 C++ 提供一个 discard 迭代器，这样我们就可以真正说所有的 thrust 奇特的迭代器都是可用的。通过我们，你的意思是更广泛的集体社区。我完全同意。我指的是你们。
I don't have time to write papers right now. We should talk about some more C++ 23 features that we're excited about. Yeah, let's just rattle off a couple. Well, there's MD-SPAN. That's actually not in Cy's list, I don't think. No, because I just realized that their list was from March, and so they haven't included any of the stuff that we've added since then. Specifically the stuff from the July committee plenary where we voted in like 60 papers. But MD-SPAN is in, which I'm quite excited about because I joined the committee back in 2015 with the purpose of
我现在没时间写论文。我们应该讨论一些我们同样兴奋的更多的 C++ 23 特性。是的，让我们随便报几个。嗯，有 MD-SPAN。这其实不在 Cy 的名单上，我不觉得。没有，因为我刚意识到他们的名单是三月份的，所以他们没有包含我们自那以后添加的任何东西。具体来说是来自七月份委员会全会的那些，我们在会上投票通过了大约 60 篇论文。但 MD-SPAN 进去了，我对此非常兴奋，因为我早在 2015 年加入委员会的目的就是
working on putting a multidimensional array type into the standard. And now, seven years later, success. And let's see what other things things um yeah let's just do rapid fire i'm looking at expected stood expected yeah let's let's just do rapid fire so we'll just mention things and then maybe in a future episode we'll uh we'll maybe we'll bring on guests or we'll just talk about these in detail but yeah stood expected super exciting um and i'm looking now sort of at the bottom of the list of things that have been added to the compiler support and this is the library side of things we'll look at language in a sec um the range fold algorithms can you name the
致力于将多维数组类型放入标准中。现在，七年过去了，成功了。让我们看看还有什么别的，嗯，让我们快速过一遍，我正在看 expected，std expected，是的，让我们，让我们快速过一遍，所以我们只需提及一些东西，然后在未来的剧集中，我们可能会，我们可能会请嘉宾，或者我们只是详细讨论这些，但是的，std expected 超级令人兴奋，我现在正在看已经添加到编译器支持的东西列表的底部，这是库方面的事情，我们一会儿会看语言，range fold 算法，你能说出
four fold algorithms that got added c++ 23 i was i was gonna bring those up um i can't name them aren't they all aren't they all just spellings of Fold? There's Fold Left. Yep, that's correct. One out of four. I actually got, I did a whole talk and mentioned them and got one of the names wrong. So you're off the hook for messing up. I gave a whole talk and still messed it up.
C++ 23 中添加的四个 fold 算法吗？我本来要提起那些的……我叫不出它们的名字，它们不都只是 Fold 的拼写吗？有 Fold Left。是的，正确。四分之一个。我其实，我做了一个完整的演讲并提到了它们，结果其中一个名字说错了。所以你搞砸了也没关系。我做了一个完整的演讲还是把它搞砸了。
I did share the meetings where these things were voted in. But that's the problem is that the names change so many times. I honestly couldn't tell you what the final names were. Yeah, so Fold Left is the first one. Fold right is the second one. Fold left first is the third one. And the one that I got wrong, you might be thinking, I named it fold right first.
我确实主持了投票通过这些东西的会议。但问题是名字改了太多次了。我老实说无法告诉你最终的名字是什么。是的，所以 Fold Left 是第一个。Fold right 是第二个。Fold left first 是第三个。我弄错的那一个，你可能会想，我把它命名为 fold right first。
That is wrong. Scratch that from ever having heard it in my talk. It's fold right last, which I don't know how I feel about that. I kind of like the first first. But anyways, and these are the equivalents if you're a Haskell programmer of fold L, fold L1, fold R, and fold R1. The difference being is that the ones without the underscore first and underscore last suffix,
那是错的。从你听过我的演讲中抹去这一点。它是 fold right last，我不知道我对此做何感想。我有点喜欢第一个 first。但无论如何，如果你是 Haskell 程序员，这些相当于 fold l、fold l1、fold r 和 fold r1。区别在于，没有下划线 first 和下划线 last 后缀的那些
they don't take initial values. Whereas the ones that are just called fold left and fold right they do take initial values and the difference that that impacts the algorithms in that the ones that don't take initial values the underscore first and underscore last version have to return an optional which means because if you're given an empty range what do you return uh you can't return anything because because you don't know what to return you don't even have a single element and you don't have an initial value uh that you can return therefore you return an optional and if you're given a an empty sequence you're going to just get back the the stood
它们不接受初始值。而那些被称为 fold left 和 fold right 的则接受初始值，这会影响算法的不同之处在于，不接受初始值的那些，带有下划线 first 和下划线 last 版本的必须返回一个 optional，这意味着因为如果你给定一个空的 range，你返回什么？你什么也返回不了，因为你不知道返回什么，你甚至连一个单一的元素都没有，而且你也没有一个初始值可以返回，因此你返回一个 optional，如果你给定一个空的序列，你将只得到 std
colon colon null opt thing um standard where did i read this one it was standard library modules not something that uh is gonna super affect the way we write a line of code but it's very important um well what do you mean i mean it what is modularizing the standard library correct yes but it's going to change the way that everybody includes the standard library yeah so consumes code but like not i mean it it changes the way you write your import or include statements but you won't you will buddy buddy buddy buddy buddy what you it's modules lazily load on all the major implementations. So there is some cost dependent on the size of the module.
冒号冒号 null opt 那个东西，标准库模块，这不是一个会对我们编写代码的方式产生巨大影响的东西，但它非常重要……嗯，你是什么意思？我的意思是，什么是模块化标准库？对，是的。但这会改变每个人包含标准库的方式，是的，所以它消耗代码，但像，不，我的意思是，它改变了你写 import 或 include 语句的方式，但你不会，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，你……在所有主要的实现上，模块都是延迟加载的。因此存在一些取决于模块大小的成本。
But in comparison to headers, which are textual, the cost is trivial. And that's why we have one big std module. And what that means is... That's why I didn't mention anything about cost. I just said it won't technically affect the way you write code. It drastically will affect the way that you write code. You'll no longer have to think about what header am I including? Which standard library header am I including? You'll just import
但与是文本的头文件相比，成本微不足道。这就是为什么我们有一个大的 std 模块。这意味着……这就是为什么我没有提到任何关于成本的事。我只说过它在技术上不会影响你写代码的方式。它将极大地影响你写代码的方式。你将不再需要考虑我在包含哪个头文件？我在包含哪个标准库头文件？你只需导入
std and you'll have all of them. The way it works, the modules aren't textual. It's this internal compiler representation that has a fast index of the things. So you'll only pay for what things you use. Only those things will really have to be loaded from the module, and they can be looked up quickly. I didn't know that.
std，你就拥有了所有这些。它的工作方式是，模块不是文本的。它是这种内部编译器表示，具有事物的快速索引。所以你只需为你使用的东西付费。只有那些东西才真正需要从模块中加载，并且它们可以被快速查找。我不知道这一点。
You should have read the paper or listened to my talks on modules. So this means import stood, importing the entire standard library as a module, is faster than including only the headers that you need. And so that means that in the future, you will not think about what headers a part of the standard library is in. You will simply import the entire standard library. And that changes how you write code. You'll no longer think about, you know, which header is this thing in or which header is that thing in.
你应该已经读过论文或者听过我关于模块的演讲了。这意味着 import std——将整个标准库作为一个模块导入——比只包含你需要的头文件还要快。这意味着在未来，你将不再需要思考标准库的某个部分在哪个头文件里。你只需要导入整个标准库。这改变了你编写代码的方式。你不再需要去想，你知道的，这个东西在哪个头文件里，或者那个东西在哪个头文件里。
You know, the, you know, oh, I forgot to add the numeric include because I included algorithms thinking that's where reduce is, but no, it's actually add the numeric include because i included algorithms thinking that's where it reduces but no it's actually in this numeric header you won't have to deal with that i mean in your defense i had no idea that this was the implications of it in my defense it still doesn't affect the way you write code it affects the way that it affects it means you don't have to think about where code lives and you don't have to go include hash include angle header from this and remember oh yeah numerics in algorithm there are there are features that people don't use today because they are in a header with a bunch of other things and they don't want to pay the cost of including the header and in the future world of a modular standard library
你知道的，哦，我忘了添加 numeric 头文件，因为我包含了 algorithms，以为 reduce 在那里，但其实不是，实际上它在 numeric 头文件中，你再也不用应付这些了。我是说，为你辩解一下，我以前根本不知道会产生这种影响。为我辩解一下，这仍然不会影响你编写代码的方式，它影响的是——这意味着你不用去想代码放在哪里，你也不用去写 include 尖括号加上某个头文件，然后去记“哦，对，numeric 在 algorithm 里面”。现在有些功能人们不用，因为它们和一堆其他东西在一个头文件中，他们不想付出包含这个头文件的代价。而在未来模块化标准库的世界里，
maybe instead of writing you know something on own, because you don't want to pay this cost of including the entire standard library, you'll just import std and use that thing. That is a strong argument. I mean, if we were in a debate mode here, I would still say you could still write the exact same code you were writing before now. So in that sense, it's not changing it. But from that pragmatic point of view of, yes, if you were not including a certain header because of the cost of it, now potentially, and that is actually,
也许与其自己去写某些东西，因为你不想付出包含整个标准库的代价，你只需 import std 然后使用那个东西就行了。这是一个很有力的论点。我的说，如果我们现在处于辩论模式，我还是会说，你依然可以写出和以前完全一模一样的代码。所以从这个意义上说，它并没有改变。但从务实的角度来看，是的，如果你以前因为包含某个头文件的代价而没有包含它，现在可能就不会了，而这实际上——
I'm sure that is the case for some people out in the wild, that they're not including this because it hurts compile time too much. We've all seen lightning talks or talks that show, hey, look what happens when I include this single header, and boom, it explodes compile time. All right, we'll leave it there, folks. Stay tuned. This is probably episode 91 that you're finishing listening to. Episode 92, if all things go according to plan, we'll have Kate Gregory on.
我确信现实中确实有人因为包含某个头文件对编译时间伤害太大而选择不包含它。我们都看过闪电演讲或者其他演讲展示：嘿，看看当我包含这单个头文件时发生了什么，砰，编译时间爆炸了。好了，各位，我们就聊到这里。请继续关注。这大概是你刚听完的第 91 期节目。如果一切按计划进行，第 92 期节目我们将请来凯特·格雷戈里（Kate Gregory）。
And then maybe we'll bring Barry on after that if he wants to come on. Thanks for listening. Let us know either on Reddit or on Twitter or on our GitHub if we missed your favorite library or language feature and you want us to talk about it on a future episode. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
然后之后如果巴里（Barry）想来的话，我们也许会把他请来。谢谢收听。如果我们漏掉了你最喜欢的库或语言特性，并希望我们在以后的节目中讨论它，请在 Reddit、Twitter 或我们的 GitHub 上告诉我们。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。